I wanted to follow up on my spoiler free
video about the three body teaser with
one where I could talk about book stuff
if you haven't read the series
remembrance of Earth's past by Sistine
Liu then this video won't be for you
you'll want to check out the other one
because this one will be filled with
spoilers and with that out of the way
let's get into it the first thing that
jumped out at me when I watched this
trailer was the shots of so fun this led
to a short period of time where I
wondered if they might be including
parts from death's end since that's when
she actually has a body when you go back
and look it's pretty clear that she only
appears in the three body game and that
makes a lot more sense than anything
from the third book showing up in this
first season the shot is so fun at the
end that sets up the title Graphics
almost looks like an animation you'd see
after you died in a video game the other
shot of her walking across the destroyed
landscape looks like a tri-solar day
since the lava on this surface could be
melted rock that's probably connected to
the burning horse that shows up later in
the teaser with this being the
representation of the scene where he
almost gets burned at the stake before
he gets access to the second level
obviously the sofon project is already
in full swing by the time they start
playing the game so it doesn't seem like
a terrible idea to introduce the
character this way she could be the
visual representation of the text that
appears on the screen putting a face to
the after a long time life and
civilization will begin once more and
progress through the unpredictable world
of three body we invite you to log on
again or they could even make her one of
the characters they meet that way when
the sofons are introduced there will be
a connection that they can use to
introduce the character when it exists
in a body when they get to Destin the
coolest game seen by far is the
destruction of the three bodies Von
Newman architect your human formation
computer this is undoubtedly the effect
of the trisolar Synergy and you can see
that the soldiers aren't holding Flags
in both hands like the book but they do
have signs that are black on one side
and white on the other so they can still
make those Gates I'm really glad to see
they included this and can't wait to see
what it looks like when they fire the
computer up I'm ready to see 30 million
people making that happen I don't think
the teaser has anything beyond the
Common Era and the first book generally
except for a couple of shots that might
be from the early crisis era at the
beginning of book two there is a shot of
a ship which at first made me think of
red Coast base 2. this doesn't seem to
be a popular opinion though because when
you look closer it does look like this
is a naval vessel and because there is
what looks like a young sailor talking
to an older man you do think of Zhang
Bae Hai and his father in the dark
Forest there's a scene where he's
talking to woo UA at the beginning
beginning of the book and they bring up
his father so I guess they could switch
things up some and have him talking to
his father in front of this ship when it
comes down to it we are going to jump
through time obviously but most of these
characters are Common Era men and women
for an example we don't see him in this
teaser but Liam Cunningham is listed as
playing Thomas Wade who doesn't appear
until much later in the book which
should be fun because this is a total
reversal of the Davos character he
played in Game of Thrones and as it is
with most of these characters who show
up later we get flashbacks to the Common
Era when they're introduced so I guess
in an ensemble cast it makes sense to
have things play out in chronological
order as long as you can afford to hire
these actors to stay on for multiple
Seasons we're gonna have to wait until
closer to The Season's release when we
get a more comprehensive trailer to
really sort out what the season will
cover but knowing that it's only eight
episodes I hope they aren't planning on
doing more than the big event events
from the first book it would be hard for
me to imagine them getting through
introducing the wall facer project for
example so this other shot that I
thought might be from the early crisis
era was the shot of the airplane on the
runway this made me think of Dasha
taking luoji to the United Nations so
maybe these will be part of a final
episode that sets up the next season I
think overall it's too early to tell one
thing I notice about this Naval vessel
is that it does appear to be flying the
flag of the United Kingdom so if this is
the Zhang Bay High character I guess
they have switched his country of origin
and speaking of the cast that is the
biggest hang-up I had with this teaser
and possibly the project overall from
the way I understand it several of these
western actors that they hired will be
working together to sort of take over
the role of Wong meow and when it comes
to things like this I always try to
figure out what kind of a problem are
they trying to solve by doing this this
is a big change this is a Chinese story
I think that's part of the appeal and
none of these characters they brought on
to replace a male Chinese character are
Chinese men we do have Benedict Wong
playing dashir which means that he could
possibly be interacting with Jess Hong's
character for a Chinese storyline and
then maybe she's the one who sees the
countdown on her pictures although there
is this shot of them Written in Blood on
a wall that I'm not exactly sure what
that is that seems to be a new thing for
the show but I love that whole situation
with the number so I'm willing to to
give it a chance so what problem are
they trying to solve the first thing
that comes to mind and sort of makes
sense is that much of what Wong meow
does involves him figuring out things in
his head having multiple people working
through that together makes sense as far
as conveying what's happening to the
audience this is a typical thing that
happens when you go from a book to the
visual medium but in that situation
these are supposed to be five brilliant
scientists who were former colleagues
who find themselves affected by yahweh's
decision to respond to the trisolarians
who come together to confront the
greatest threat in Humanity's history
knowing how things develop from here why
couldn't all five scientists be Chinese
after all the show naturally gets more
International as you get into the wall
facer project and go beyond that so are
they worried that a primarily Asian cast
would be a tough sell to an
international audience and I suppose I
should say that it's probably more
complicated Netflix isn't technically
available in China they aren't able to
do business there because of the way
things are regulated and I mean it is a
huge market and I'm sure they aren't
happy about that but I can't really say
if that's a factor I guess I don't want
to jump to conclusions but this doesn't
look great at this point the only reason
that sort of makes sense the only
problem that this kind of solves is that
if the season one cast was primarily
Chinese and everything takes place in
China than most people in the target
audience which is the rest of the world
would be watching with subtitles and for
non-english speakers I know this doesn't
make any sense and you do have examples
out there like dark or squid game that
have been huge successes but for every
one of those there are dozens of
non-english shows that underperform
because Americans aren't used to having
to read subtitles when they watch TV
that could be a legitimate reason to
make the cast more International we are
talking about a corporation which means
it's baked in that profits Drive
decisions I don't think having a Chinese
cast all speaking English in China would
be a popular idea either but you do have
to wonder if it doesn't lose some of
what made it so interesting to begin
with and I don't want to make excuses
for anyone involved with this I'll watch
it and see if it works and I'm hoping
that it does because I am a huge fan of
this story I suppose if you put a gun to
my head and said you could only choose
two characters who could be played by
Chinese actors it would be yahwan Jay
and luoji but then I look at this
casting sheet on the three Body website
and there isn't a Chinese actor who
could play luo if they are introducing
him in the first season which is a maybe
hinging mostly on that shot of the
airplane looking at this cast I would
think he's probably being played by
Sameer uzumni he's one of the two actors
on here they don't include in that group
of five colleagues that are coming back
together which in my mind Lou OG or
whatever they call the character in the
show shouldn't be a part of that Ben
snetzer is the other one but they have
him listed as playing a young Mike Evans
samara's character is named Raj Varma
which doesn't directly connect to
anything for me so I guess we'll have to
wait and see how that plays out another
thing that jumped out at me about this
trailer was how good everything from
yahwan Jay's past looks I would have
liked to seen a red rectangle that looks
like a space bar for the button she
pushes every time I see a picture of the
sun I think of the term star Pluckers
and all these years later that still
makes me laugh a little the wide shots
of the crowd during the cultural
revolution look fantastic I have no idea
if normal citizens stood in the crowd
holding up their little red books like
that but I understand what the visual is
trying to convey and it does seem like
they pulled off the look of this time
period here and in red Coast base 1. I
was glad to see they included the
struggle session which the 10 cent
version omitted because that is an
important part of this character's
development I guess what I worry about
is that the eto's backstory is about
being disillusioned with Humanity not
with China and since the end of World
War II westerners have been raised with
anti-communist propaganda so I hope the
show can anticipate how that might lead
to them missing the point I think a key
part of the experience of reading this
book that the show has to capture is
that when she pushes the button you're
not sure how to feel about it of course
it feels like a betrayal she's dooming
her species our species but as you
struggle with that you realize that many
people would react in the exact same way
this is an area where some some of those
cast changes might make a difference
Wong meow didn't buy into the eto's
message he teamed up with Dasha so on
the one hand having International
characters here could reinforce the idea
of people being disillusioned by
Humanity across the globe because we do
see them playing the game and therefore
they're connected to the ETO but on the
other hand if they're replacing Wong
meow then there's a chance of a bad
reading of this all being set in motion
by the harsh treatment she received at
the hands of her government the book
does a good job of balancing this out
and making that disillusionment
Universal they introduced Mike Evans who
comes from the opposite end of the
spectrum as far as his upbringing is
concerned and his views turn out to be
more radical than hers again this is all
based on speculation and motivated by
the fear that something I like might get
painted in a different light and that
might make me like this version of it
less objectively nothing in this brief
tease user undermines what's essential
to the series and I don't want to go
around projecting things and I don't
think it hints that there will be a
major shift in what these characters do
in relation to the overarching theme so
I don't think there's a reason to jump
to the conclusion that this will take on
some pro-western slant at least not yet
there is a ton of fascinating stuff to
work with here the visuals do look
amazing the game shots all look
fantastic and I thought it was kind of
funny how I saw some responses from
people saying why does it look like a
video game these Graphics look terrible
when you know it is actually a video
game there's an interesting shot there
where I yelled rehydrate rehydrate
rehydrate at my screen when I was
watching it it brings up an interesting
question of how they'll deal with
showing the trisolarians on screen not
showing what they looked like was a big
part of the story but I'm not exactly
sure how you get around that for TV of
course this rehydrate scene is in the
game so they'll look like people that's
how it looked in the story and you've
already seen that with the soldiers and
the computer scene but if they go there
to show The Listener and to show the
sofons being created they will have to
decide how to depict them there's
another cool looking shot of a scientist
committing suicide initially I thought
this might be related to a particle
accelerator in some way but the internet
tells me this is a neutrino Observatory
which is something I had to look up
regardless of that it does make for a
great visual according to the Wiki page
these things seem to be spread out all
over the globe so it doesn't really say
anything about who this character is so
I guess I'll wrap this up by saying what
I hope they're able to pull off in this
adaptation one of the things I like the
most about this story is it makes you
think about these things on a social
level on a civilizational level because
you have this crisis but it can't be
solved in real real time it's not
immediate you've got more than 400 years
to wait for this thing to happen that
leaves room for things to develop in
captivating ways in the first season I
think they have to nail why pushing this
button makes sense why people are drawn
to the ETO even if you don't agree with
any of the factions that make it up and
the lingering dread that follows the
your bugs message if they can land those
points that sets up things perfectly for
the Dark Forest and the story just takes
off from there and if you come to find
that you're not interested in this take
it's not faithful enough to the source
of material then the 10 cent version
does exist it won't let you down in that
department a lot of book readers really
adore this to the point of it almost
being a purity test for how much of a
fan you are which I kind of get I read
the entire fanfic book and I even
watched the Minecraft stuff whenever I
was at that point of just wanting more
of this world like in any form so I do
get that as a book reader I enjoyed
seeing those things again in the 10 cent
version as a guy who watches TV and
talks about it on YouTube it's not up
there with my favorite shows or my
favorite things I've seen for me the
books will always be the best version
because in that format it's just me and
my imagination if you like those you
might like that show if you haven't read
them then just read them or listen to
the audio version I did learn that
there's a six hour edit of the 10 cent
show that was originally 22 hours long
which might be great but I haven't seen
it yet season two of that version of the
show has been announced and they also
announced that that should spin-off that
might fill in some of the blanks and
I'll definitely be checking that out we
have six months before the Netflix
version comes out and I'm optimistic
I'll be revisiting the series between
now and then I have some videos in mind
that will hopefully turn some people on
to it and that's what I hope to see at
the end of the day a good adaptation
soon that brings people to this story
and has them grapple with some of these
ideas it's been a lot of fun for me and
I think that's a great place to leave
things please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign